es ist ein fall der uns besonders bewegt
hat anfang des jahres dem mord an dieser
jungen frau 23 jahre alt eine werdende
stewardess sie wurde brutal erstochen
und das von einem mann der sie angeblich
liebte sie wollte ihren traumberuf leben
stewardess sophie in ihre koffer hatte
sie schon gepackt voller vorfreude auf
ein leben und arbeiten über den wolken
doch sie wurde brutal erstochen von
diesem mann der sie hasste weil er von
sophie nicht geliebt wurde immer wieder
lauerte er ihr auf bombardierte sie mit
anrufen späte sie aus schließlich
wartete er in sophies wohnung stach ihm
mit einem messer in den hals
soviel starb mit nur 23 jahren
beigesetzt in einem schneeweißen kleid
an ihrem eichensarg sophies gitarre mit
dem roten schmetterling und in hannover
ist jetzt ein bildreporter mirko voltmer
hallo volk mit hallo milka tschuldigung
logistisch ja heute wollen die
anklageschrift vorgetragen hat sich der
täter mittlerweile geäußert nein
patrick es bliebt auf anraten seiner
verteidiger erst mal dabei nichts sagen
zu wollen was den vorsitzenden richter
stephan lohse etwas überraschte so wie
er selbst heute sagte
nach der anklageverlesung und
appellierte an den angeklagten
er möge doch bitte reden das hat
folgenden hintergrund patrick es ist
damals nach der tat zur polizei deshalb
gegangen sagte ich habe einen menschen
getötet und seither schweigt er
und herr jositsch betonte heute aber
ganz viele fragen und es wurde auch den
angeklagten helfen wenn er diese fragen
beantworten würde
der prozess geht jetzt am 16 juli weiter
und hatte patrick es hat noch die chance
weiterhin sich zu äußern er wolle
momentan noch das psychiatrische
gutachten abwarten des sachverständigen
der im prozess sitzt das opfer so viel
war 23 jahre erst alt waren ihre eltern
auch beim prozess vor ort ja das war die
mutter war heute davon so viel und für
sie war es unglaublich schwierig hier
rein ins landgericht das konnte man ja
regelrecht ansehen sie hat ganz tapfer
sich diese grausigen details der anklage
angehört
hat versucht den täter möglichst nicht
anzugucken direkt und nachdem hier der
prozess sagt vorbei gewesen ist brach es
aus ihr heraus sie brach ihr zusammen
und brach in tränen aus und war wirklich
mit dem mit den nerven fertig danke
schön mirko voltmer aus hannover